when you see this what does this mean
it's like abbreviated stuff how would
you read out this yeah Christian
probability what is the probability of a
particular event whatever you like
dealing out the two of hearts rolling or
six gonna kill by Baltimore that kind of
thing okay probably a bit of it and it's
a fraction right it's a fraction sorry
it's been walking we've written this a
couple of times already what is the top
and bottom what are the top and bottom
of this fraction massive favorable yeah
i'm going to write events because events
and outcomes same ID and someone else
tell me the denominator yeah i'm going
to add on the word total their total
possible events for napkins right and by
the way we have another name that is
well once i call starts with 3 s's
safest place very good okay so this is
the probability of an event okay now
what I want to introduce to you is the
language of complementary events okay do
you remember you don't have to write
this putt just watch this on the side
when you are playing our game yesterday
which happen autumn or right there was a
probability of rolling a six in theory
at theoretical probability was they will
add events how many sixes are there on a
dime well it's just one and how many
possible numbers are six good good good
now that's a probability of getting
killed the problem you stay a why of not
getting killed by you can write that in
two ways the first way pulls on this
complementary event like you right I can
just say not six right I can say not six
now that's not the only way i can write
it i can write it as the probably of one
two three four or five but do you see
why i prefer the first way what what's
better about my shorts it's just quick
off just quicker you guys know
mathematicians famously lazy will always
take the quickest part weekend okay now
look at this for a second it's really
easy you don't have to do any
collation to know what the probability
of not getting a six is what is the
problem you can you can see there are
five favorable events I've written them
there one two three four and five it's
fine and it's still it's still six in
total do you agree with that okay but I
want you to look at these two numbers
that I've written on the board this
probability and this probability what
did they add up to what about to
Christian 1 now 2 1 which means these
are all the possible things so
underneath we've written in here right
the probability of a complementary event
right this is like the opposite of your
event happening right if you were
thinking on stix's the complementary
that is not a 6 if you're thinking about
odd numbers what's the complementary
eroticism on a diet you're either odd
numbers or you're even numbers right
we'll see so odds is one event evens is
the complementary memory can you see the
probability is just one take away the
probability of the actual event you're
interested in do you see that right I
could arrive at this by saying it's one
take away our sins do you agree with
that do you see how my numbers work so
maybe you want to label the fact with a
better color that a complementary event
is the opposite of the event
okay so bottom even that works six or
not six that works quick question let's
think about this you're playing a soccer
game win or lose are they complemented
Ennis yes they are not put the victory
events because there's another option
time right so it's win or not with those
are the complementary what about our
without sunny or rainy are those company
no no because I could have like overcast
or smelly all kinds of things yeah you
could have had it with a chance of
meatballs or Fatima to try to be forced
to um you can see you can see there's
other things possible so you could say
sunny not sunny there would be
complimentary or raining not ready they
will be complimentary and you can use
this rather like count them all up you
can just subtract